let's talk about a movie that does exist
well that's what I still have some time
here at your home this jaws movie on
pitchin come straight out the only other
person maybe he lets change a do it he
might and why wouldn't you let JJ do
anything in this world including your
wife right in front of you
after you watch that [ __ ] trailer for
Star Wars :
the last Skywalker the rise Star Wars :
the rise of SCOE I think they call in
through you you did a rise of Skywalker
now let's start with the title yeah does
that bother you at all no mmm does me
come on bro bothers me it sounds like a
fan film or a video game
it doesn't sound you know how all the
titles have sort of been sweeping in
general and sort of encapsulate a whole
yes world yes it seems so ultra specific
may I to the land to the Skywalker clan
man I know there's the center of the
story bus but I propose what these
proposed like this and this has I have
no knowledge whatsoever I you know to be
fair or full disclosure I did visit yes
tower set but this is not information
that I gleaned all right I had no idea
what the title was until they [ __ ]
dry out no one did but looking at that
title these are the things that went
swirling around my head the obvious
thing is like well I mean the obvious
thing is marketing-wise
[ __ ] brilliant because the last movie
the big complaint is like what the what
the what but Luke Skywalker what so put
it right in the toilet hey kid sky walk
like you're getting one of them it's
that's this is on a marketing level that
absolutely makes sense story level now
I'm going okay it could be like you know
after unfairly killing him off in the
last one he's coming back and it's a
literal title it's about the rise of
coward or could be that after all this
time we find out Rey is a Skywalker
right or it could be the [ __ ] guy low
is because isn't he a Skywalker or was
he a solo he's been he's half and half I
mean his mom was a Skywalker it does
the title does for me what [ __ ] like
it without knowing anything excites the
[ __ ] out of me cuz I'm like the endless
possibilities but here's one that could
be and this is again shot in the dark
what if you know last movie was the last
Jedi right what if they are telling it's
the [ __ ] time you know like you know
come on all the titles and boma what if
that is like a title what if the way
that Jedi has been used historically in
these movies mm-hmm and like including
in the last moments Jedi's the last Jedi
the Jedi's must end and all that [ __ ]
right what if that's it for the Jedi's
no and perhaps the new religion are the
Skywalker's didn't that just give you
[ __ ] chills that nipples pop that got
me a little stiff wilter JIT what is the
movement what if it's that and I swear
again [ __ ] I don't want anybody going
like you know I know that's all
speculation this is just when I read
that title cuz I too was when it when it
dropped I was like they put the name
right there and that's these are all the
thoughts that when I say you're saying
and in that exactly Skywalker supplants
the the order that would existed before
hands that'd be [ __ ] dope what an
honor
[ __ ] important like I'm gonna cry to
the universe that from then on they
named the order after they're all
Skywalker's well you think it the
Christians the Christians adopted a
guy's name to call their religion we got
six months minimum maybe eight before we
get to see this picture yeah it's gonna
be such a fun [ __ ] six or eight
months to in speculation yeah but my god
it made me so happy see that opening
shot here and let's talk about the
actual trailer itself and that opening
shot is breathtaking yes it's it's like
David Lean anybody who knows Lawrence of
Arabia or any of the David Lean films a
bridge over the River Kwai I mean the
scope of that and then how it builds and
builds and builds was really sort of
breath take he is a masterful filmmaker
oh you know anybody that tries to get
away from him they're idiots at this
point like he [ __ ] that boy is born to
make movies yeah in his [ __ ] blood
like you know what I'm saying I'm carp
I came into a because my love movies JJ
born to make movies yeah and that
trailer just puts it on full [ __ ]
display let's watch it okay we could
comment through it and stuff yeah
because good lord its I didn't number
one I should have known because
celebration was happening that we'd get
it yeah I didn't Donna me either
I'm coming before JC was close enough
you think it would happen you know is
this should have been a no-brainer but I
was surprised
JC runs scum and villainy right he was
going out to Chicago to for yeah and a
celebration and I we talked about I was
like do you think they show teaser he's
like oh no it's like eight months away
he's going to it make sense but like
there's no guarantee baba block yeah and
then they [ __ ] drop this man this
that'd be a lot of reason home logo not
a breathing that's the fanboys what's
great there she is there's our girl look
at the scope and the Vista behind that
shots just gorgeous as a filmmaker right
there son there's a guy that's just
slice how to use the frame and right
away there's a great marketer who's like
there's Luke's boy showed a lightsaber
boo that sound he sounds like he's doing
Alec Guinness almost you know enemies
taking on that gravitas and we're on a
desert planet
yeah me tattooing or is this Jack cool
mmm-hmm look at that scope it just looks
like an epic and then we find ray like
see how we get quiet cuz it's just like
you're watching has its visually
stunning [ __ ] kylo Ren ship this is I
can't believe they're shown us this
sequence but what a great way that
reminded me of Darth Vader in his
fighter with those gloves on the
controls here comes this Christmas I've
seen winter I saw that Sky City BAM kylo
Ren look at this [ __ ] I love that mask
shots well to get back together yes
know Calrissian you truly belong here
with us among the stuff cloud that looks
like [ __ ] returned the Jedi right
yeah Threepio and come on bro
they gave us carry back JJ gave you
[ __ ] carry back and look the remnants
of the Death Star and then the Joker
shows up at the end
why is Hamill laughing why is Luke
laughing at the end of that can be so
happy or does something go sounds like
my name's in the title that of course
December comes a little sinister now I'm
gonna laugh for that that bother you no
love it that is the Emperor that's Ian
McDermott that's who the laugh is him
that's that's the Emperor and they
brought him out on stage to be like look
who's bad bachchi Ann McDermid under on
stage that's a celebration that's where
the laugh oh that's perfect so he's the
guy they show you a piece of the [ __ ]
Death Star which could only be the Death
Star from Return of the Jedi
right and then you hear his laugh has he
been [ __ ] living in the wreckage of
the [ __ ] Death Star on some planet
maybe it's end or maybe it's not Wow
come on bro like I don't care I know a
lot of people get cynical what did you
spoken fanservice yeah he walks yes he's
like roasting a walks eating them inside
the wreckage you made me really excited
for an idea that probably isn't in that
movie let's be honest JJ is not that
cynical a man corpses of lakhs a
brilliant
oh my god why didn't you say that before
I could have mentioned it to him or
something
poor eggs and you ox it's totally
totally it is yes it is fans're it is at
this point it's just giving the people
what does he want isn't that what we're
[ __ ] here for once you get into a
sequel you're into the fanservice
absolutely you tell your original story
you can only be so original after you've
told the first story right say that
everything has to be based on that
probably looking you know for a little
leeway as the guy that just made James
how about reboot
but yeah it's like you're in the fan
service business the only reason they're
coming back for more is cuz they're like
AWS a fan of the first one right I liked
it or even if they're just mildly like
some people would take objection like
they and [ __ ] you but it's like even if
you know it just mildly like it that's
what the sequel business is yes and this
is not only a sequel but it closes up
the entire [ __ ] saga right this is
what we're this met this is where George
Lucas was heading more or less when he
started way back in when they were
shooting in 1976 when we started seeing
these movies in 1977 and in fairness to
the franchise it's always been the plan
that it was going to be sort of cyclical
and folded back in on itself you know
what I mean it's been built that way the
family story between all of them and the
reuse of the Death Star is the weapon I
mean it or even in the first three films
that Lucas made it sort of referenced
itself and is operational
self-referential I mean you expand the
world and stuff but like at the end of
the day it's like you own the familiar
so in this trailer we get to see the
familiar they show us [ __ ] Lando and
we're like holy [ __ ] I missed him I know
we could add them in the last movie it
sounded like but great that they pull
him out but but come on like through the
magic of cinema and through the magic of
boy we didn't we have too much movie
let's leave this stuff on the cutting
room floor from the force awakens carry
lives carry [ __ ] lives
that's a slay lives in the movie like
come on not a dry eye in the house like
and they lived up to their promise
remember though like we're not gonna do
digital carry yeah and got some we got
something in the bag so I like you know
Luke's in it right we're hearing his
voice I don't think those are lines from
last movie are they not tonight
not that I recall my only thing I was
like is that Luke from the previous
movie that way they're leaving it a
question mark but if you put Skywalker
in the title guess who's gonna be in
that movie yeah Luke [ __ ] Skywalker
himself so we know we got Luke back we
know we get Carrie back mm-hm the
Atlanta get Lando you don't get grumpy
pants though do you you don't get grumpy
pants I guarantee you
goddamn him han Solo I don't know I know
and I'm not God and then what if they're
there and what if they can man what if
it's just here's the here's and this
again my [ __ ] spits all speculation
in theory like fog and JJ smart enough
to never share anything right with me
so this is just me talking as a fan big
complaints about these movies so far
been like man I'm not gonna get to see
Han Luke and Leia right in the same
movie ever again
together missed opportunity should have
a damn hug now this is a movie series
known for the use of force folks do have
some ghosts popping in from time to time
so with some with some very agreeable
nodding going on everybody's always very
happy in their world
Hey atta boy good job you really ought
to cut to one of them being like no no
shake his head go show it when they're
liking the [ __ ] and they need some help
I'm different from the missions all over
like a thumbs up buddy wink wait yeah
where were you and I needed you heads
and Egon Cloud City
where's [ __ ] Anakin Skywalker waving
them off don't have lunch around don't
have lunch don't go into the lunch room
there very conveniently sports coast but
that is a way you know to to do what has
Han has he earned the force ghost I mean
because all the force goes up till now
have been Jedi just saying he was never
ordained you gotta say though at one
point this was a movie series where
they're like you know how you get the
force blood disease like lead poisoning
so I think I think at this point we
could take liberties if we wanted to
point is maybe open audit from Leah
point is nobody knows what this [ __ ]
movie is over than JJ right I saw a
little bit when I was there but I didn't
see the only thing that's relic that was
near what I saw was at one point you see
the ship going into like this
mountain-top like city building after it
says [ __ ] you know this December or
whatever [ __ ] there's a shot of the ship
coming into like a city in the mountains
I that's I saw that that's cool and it
was huge huge you're such a big set
biggest said I ever seen I love the fact
that he still uses practicals I love him
he's such a great [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I
can't I'm telling you there's some
imperceptible part of your brain that
can tell the difference no matter how
good CGI is between something that its
existing versus something that doesn't
how long it's just adds something for me
I watched him compose a shot with a
crane gigantic [ __ ] crane gorgeous
took him like an hour like to sit there
and be like are we doing this we're
doing this we're doing this and the
whole time me the director I'm sitting
there going like oh we would be done
[ __ ] this crane closed up another glow
subbatches okay just get coverage Kyle
moving into it but then when we shot it
is breathtaking and you're like that's
why he these these great [ __ ]
filmmaker yes you can't [ __ ] take it
away from the dude is the Spielberg of
our generation right like such and
there's a reason why they went back to
him to sort of rein this whole thing in
and get this enterprise back on track
because they know he will [ __ ] do
that he brings magic and Wonder to it
not that Ryan didn't and I enjoy the
last jet I like it that's a movie that
really enjoyed like a lot of I thought
he did a really great job but you know
there there's the and I understood
exactly what he was gone for right like
it's the idea of like if we want this
saga to keep going can't just be like
remember when Han and Leia Luke Han and
Leia it's like you gotta break it to fix
it and stuff but we're just we're just
not ready to let go of Luke on lay you
know and I'm saying like it's it's still
their story and a lot of our my world
and it feels like this one will tie it
up where you're like okay man okay now
what's next yeah like that's the and if
again all [ __ ] speculation but if
rise of Skywalker meant that they were
the next order of
were called the Skywalker's how
beautiful that saga is about a little
boy that they find in the desert who
becomes the savior whose name becomes
like and that name I'm gonna cry just
thinking about it if you call them
Skywalker's and again this is just
speculation it's all just a stoner
talking about movies but if you do not
only as an honor for Luke and it says
that he truly is the master and this is
a guy who trained with Ben Kenobi and
Yoda himself right like they don't call
them the Yoda's they'd be calling them
the Skywalker's if this is the case
their softball team over I believe is
gonna be Otis the traveling team squad
guys so but not only doesn't do that and
it's an honor for Luke it redeems the
name of this father right Anakin
Skywalker the little boy who was fell to
the dark side and this I think will be
about balance right there like this is
what we were getting in the last movie
the lines not so much about good guys
and bad guys a light said there's
balance they need each other right their
eyes trying to excuse the fact that Anna
gets come your uncrazy killed everybody
turned out Darth Vader they got a
redeeming with you so on on it just
excites me in a way that like and I'm
not this takes nothing away from last
Jedi but like this got my [ __ ]
imagination going yeah in a way where
I'm like oh and that's what movie should
do yes movies should ultimately
entertain maybe I should rephrase it
that's what a trailer should do right
set your imagination on [ __ ] fire the
movie they'll tell you the story and
then whether you agree with that later
on you know it's [ __ ] - depends on
here's my fear though with this
particular if there are no fears there's
a fear leads to the dark side Brown
you're not fear if you're nah there's no
try good my fear is with this fan base
is that that speculation leads to
disappointment because the dream they
come up with all these fantastical
emotions and things they want to see and
then if the movie doesn't deliver on
that promise that they've created in
their own heads there's anger at the
other end of that and then then trolling
well you know I think it's great to
speculate and I hope people do and I
hope they get excited about it but also
I hope they accept the film on
its own merits when it gets delivered
and just appreciated and enjoy it do you
think creates that I have no idea but
I'm really unhappy with it why did we go
from just like yeah man I love that
movie to like you know how it'd be
better well I don't know how excitement
waiting for something to happen then
becomes a rage if it doesn't it doesn't
go by your rules that you've created in
your head for what it should be and the
ownership of it is is odd to me and I
and I ultimately just disappointing I'm
a fan of things I might say I do to
established like Melissa Villa Senor
she's yet to disappoint me right this is
not a slam by any stretch of the
imagination but I loved Twin Peaks when
it first aired on ABC back in the day
yes it was [ __ ] groundbreaking it's a
big part of my mythology it's in my DNA
it winds up in everything I [ __ ] do
that's how important that's that series
was to me but I've been to listen and
isn't in it I could draw your line from
that to tusk you don't get to tusk
unless you go through [ __ ] twin peaks
like David Lynch in my DNA got you big
fan Mulholland Drive [ __ ] blue velvet
like wild at heart these were the movies
that made me the person and the
filmmaker that I would become that all
being said they made another Twin Peaks
recently yes
and like I applauded his ability to be
able to pull together big-budget pull
together the cast make the exact thing
that he wanted to make right it didn't
feel like the Twin Peaks I was familiar
was very loosely connected to the
original Twin Peaks yes it felt very
were like Inland Empire with a Susanoo
chillin peak sometime it was almost
unrecognizable as Twin Peaks was
completely different with the exception
of the fact I'm like well they weren't
Twin Peaks yeah right
that being said I I was never unhappy
did you ever hear me say anything about
this pump didn't write a strongly worded
letter was I on Twitter going like you
[ __ ]
how do you read hope you rot in hell if
anything I was like alright well maybe
I'm getting old and
oh that's and he's older than me yes so
he made me feel old when I'm like that
dude still on the [ __ ] edge right
where he [ __ ] belongs and my tastes
have obviously [ __ ] changed and yeah
you know you can make the argument that
like kept that wasn't really twin Biggs
but that's not the point the point is he
said something really smart I think
where my friend Vincent Brera told me
this he was like you know there's a
scene in the twin peaks' reboot where
they talk about like coffee where he
came in for coffee and then he's got to
drink this green tea and stuff and he's
like yeah but why don't you just try it
like you might actually like the green
teas go but I came in here for coffee
and he's like that pretty much sums up
the Twin Peaks reboot which is like
right you came in for coffee but we gave
you something that's not coffee but it's
pretty [ __ ] tasty and you know if
you're in the mood for coffee and it
seems like this generations in the mood
for exactly what they want you know
maybe it's because I'm older maybe
because I'm like look I'm just happy
people but can still impress me with
this [ __ ] yeah I'm happy that I can
still like be like wow what a great
magic trick don't you don't have to make
the twin peaks' I want to see I'm glad
he's making Twin Peaks I hope he makes
nine more maybe one of them is closer to
the one that I [ __ ] recall and [ __ ]
but like I applaud his ability to like
expand his world and tell a different
[ __ ] story altogether
but I'm never like gonna [ __ ] get out
there and campaign and be like this is
horseshit what he's done to us is wrong
like be a fan don't be a fanatic yeah
and I know one word derives from the
other but like yeah I don't know maybe
we're maybe that's what separates us
from the next generation oh thank you
for that Kevin I'm glad you allowed me
to make the thing I wanted to make
you're welcome mr. Lynch he lives up
he's right there he's listening through
the window and I know people will hear
this and say well Ralph's the guy who
shoots a shadow over Batman vs. Superman
in Man of Steel and everything and it's
like yes but you know that's also kind
of what I do professionally
professionally
job is to have a take and and maybe blow
that take a little bit out of proportion
and try to make it and as entertaining
as possible by raging in something but
you don't see me out in the real world
doing it you know I've never once been
with Ralph and had him be like you know
what I really feel about this college
scandal
he's got no skin in the game but it's
like professionally I gotta use the
material it's handed to me you know so
he gives me a bolt of cloth I got to
make some clothing that's his only
spinning okay it is yeah man they're
theirs they're gonna make a I'm excited
I'm excited all the [ __ ] money
yes all right Lisa
[Music]